women don't feel like they need men in a
physical sense because life is soft but
it's but it's but it's [__] and it's
[__] because you still need Men by
proxy one and two the second life gets
difficult you very quickly you very
quickly learn how much you need men but
women don't go I'm an independent I
don't need no man because I haven't only
fans and Men be my only fans and if
anyone comes up to me I'll call a male
police officer I don't need men shut up
[__] idiot of course you do you just
named your whole life it's based on
[__] men the roads are driving on was
paved by a man the house you're living
in was built by a man the car you're
driving who was designed by a man your
whole life depends on man